[Musique]
c'était tout juste après la guerre dans
un petit balke avait souffert sur une
piste de mise et il y en avait 2 a
découvert parmi les gravats y danser
dans ce petit bal qui s'appelait qui
s'appelait qui s'appelait qui s'appelait
non je ne me souviens plus du nom du bal
perdu ce dont je me souviens c'est de
ces amoureux qui ne regardaient rien
lautour de y avait tendance ou science
dans leur geste est ému
alors qu'est l'emportant 6
le nom du balles perdues non je ne me
souviens plus du nom du bal perdu ce
dont je me souviens ce qu'ils étaient
heureux des yeux au fond des yeux mais
sans type b 1
[Musique]
il buvait dans le même verre toujours
sans se quitter des yeux
il faisait la même prière d'être
toujours toujours heureux parmi les
gravats il souriait dans ce petit bal
qui s'appelait qui s'appelait qui
s'appelait s'appelait non je ne me
souviens plus du nom du bal perdu ce
dont je me souviens c'est de ces
amoureux qui ne regardaient rien
autour d'eux
il avait tendance ou science dans leur
gestion et me alors que l'important
c'est le nom du balles perdues non je ne
me souviens plus du nom du bal perdu ce
dont je me souviens ce qu'il s'était
trouvé au fond des yeux c'était bien
c'est à dire
et puis quand l'accordéoniste s'est
arrêtée ils sont partis le soir tombé
dessus de la piste sur les gravats et
sur ma vie il était redevenu tous
tristes ce petit bal qui s'appelait qui
s'appelait s'appelait qui s'appelait non
je ne me souviens plus du nom du bal
perdu ce dont je me souviens c'est de
ces amoureux qui ne regardaient rien
autour d'eux y avait tant de lumière
avec eux dans la rue alors la belle
affaire
le nom du balles perdues non je ne me
souviens plus du nom du bal perdu ce
dont je me souviens c'est qu'on était
heureux les yeux au fond des yeux
c'était bien
[Musique]